so
um people have seen the strange group
talk
a couple people okay i just want to drag
people through that's something we've
already heard um so tim's
fins and i spent the last couple of
months building this thing that we call
arcadia
and it's an integration of closure which
everyone here knows
into unity which some of you here know
unity is a video game engine that i've
been using for the past five years
to develop games which is what i do for
a living it's an
industry standard uh it's an industry
standard tool to build games it exports
to my favorite screen community if you
guys can see that
pc mac linux ios android
xbox playstation
and wii and like basically everything
you can ever want you know
a video game to run on this this will
exploit it it's free to use
it's built on mono uh architected very
very well
and it's it's their goal is to
democratize game development so
it's really meant to be easy to pick up
and it is um
but you get a really powerful sort of
graphics system uh with it
um so what we did is we built all the
work that david miller
has done to port closure to the clr the
microsoft common language one time
um and we basically
forked and hacked the compiler and got
it to run inside of media
so what we're going to show tonight is
not you know some kind of
network interop thing this is like code
actually running inside of the
editor and when you export your games
your apps um
you know it's closure running inside the
exported apps uh this is the first
talk that we've given on this that we're
gonna do no slides i'm just gonna dive
right into live
coding so if the building collapses or
like terrible things happen
uh it's playing way more buggy compiling
keep that in mind so we're gonna we're
gonna build it i'm gonna build a game
i'm gonna go flappy bird for you guys
that's that's the plan uh and if that
doesn't work i i've already built flappy
birds so there are like little plants
here that i follow
but in doing that um i'm going to try
and give you guys a sort of overview of
unity
why unity is interesting and exciting um
and
how closure arcadia integrates with that
system if anybody has any questions at
any point so you'll find them right next
year
um if anybody has any questions at any
point please
don't hesitate don't haven't asked so
this is unity
um you have a couple of things going on
you have a thing called
this is your scene view where you could
sort of uh
set up your level or your game
select object here you have your
inspector that gives you
information on any currently selected
object
you have your hierarchy uh which is
basically a list of all the objects that
are currently in the game project
this is a list of all the files that are
going into your project
and the very important console which i
spent a lot of time looking at
so unity is an exciting target for
closure because
uh in addition to being a very powerful
graphics
system uh it's built on what's called
the entity component system model which
is a fairly standard
design pattern in the video games
industry so that
the professional video games industry is
largely still
based on c plus plus um but they've more
or less abandoned
traditional inheritance in most cases so
you don't really build deeply
necessarily
what you end up doing is you write
classes
in a very shallow inherent street that
are called components
and those components implement the
behavior of your game
and then you attach those components to
objects so
in this kind of system the way the unity
works there's no special camera object
uh in in the engine there's a there's a
game object which is generic with a
camera component attached to it
this allows you to like mix and match
the functionality and behavior in a way
that for a video game is very very
important
to be able to like remix things um
so you get that with uh
with unity and unity makes an effort to
make all of its components
serializable so they have a data only on
disk representation
which makes it play very very nicely
closures persons and data structures
which tim is going to show you guys
in a bit so this is the scene view i can
create
you know create a cube
uh it's 3d right
um but you can switch into 2d mode which
is you know just uh
ignores one of the axes more or less um
you see when i select the cube i can see
all the information
on the cube so to start building our
world
who here is played flappy bird
so flappy bird is a game that is
interesting for
historical and political reasons but
also the mechanic is very very simple
you're a bird that's flapping through a
series of pipes of varying heights
and if you hit up high queues that's the
entire game
so the first thing i want to do i took
the liberty of
grabbing a spreadsheet for flappy bird
i don't see that see all the art
so in 2d games you'll very typically
pack all of your art into a single image
and unity is very very good with that
just to show off a lot of unity's
features
you're able to sort of automatically
split up
all the assets into separate little sub
sprites
so we're going to be using these guys
for the pipes and this little animation
for the bird
so i've already split those up and i'm
going to create
an empty game object i'm going to
position it at 0
0 can you guys at all read what's going
on in this column
no i'll try i'll try and read out to
them
we don't have any zooming unfortunately
um so so i just created an empty game
object and positioned it at the origin
i'm going to add a component so this is
the bread and butter of what you do in
unity which is create objects and attach
components to them
in this case i'm going to attach a
sprite renderer because i want to draw
art i'll draw 2d art and i'm going to
choose
this background there we go a little
background
so back here
and i'm going to go back to my camera
just zoom in a little bit
and set the background color to white
and you're not really supposed to
stretch out sprites but
there we go so there's our background so
the
another thing that makes unity an
exciting target is that as opposed to
talking directly to opengl which is
perfectly fine there's nothing wrong
with that but unity is exciting because
you have this entire authoring tool
right so i've been doing a lot of stuff
in the ruffle and a lot of stuff in
closure
but there's some stuff that you just
want to be able to rough in right and
unity gives you that you present this
entire editor so there's my background
and that can just say put i'm going to
i'm going to rename the object to
bg that background uh so now
uh first thing i want to try and do is
create the pipes so in flappy bird you
have this sort of
infinite barrage of pipes that are
coming at you and you have to fly around
so to do that i'm going to create
another empty game object
i'm going to add a component it's also
going to be a sprite render
but this time i'm going to choose this
upright pipe
and it's not showing because of the z
order
there's a spring
so you can see that the scene view on
top is where you can sort of lay things
out
and the game view on the bottom is what
the final product will be
this is the sort of perspective of the
camera that's in the world
the camera which of course can also
itself be moved
again everything's fully 3d even when
you're making a 2d game
which is nice to be able to get like an
exploded view of
what it is that you're doing
do you have to set like the default like
with the size
of to like phone is it like at a phone
setting right now or is it
oh it's a free aspect right now you can
set it to
um yeah you can feed it specific
resolutions and set that up
unity tries really hard to not have
specific pixel dimensions so
their goal is to be as cross-platform as
possible but yeah you can kind of force
it to be a particular resolution
that's also important for installations
where the projector is going to be your
fixed
resolution so there are ways to do that
but right now it's whatever the
size of the the window is so grow and
shrink
this is not going to break it but um
yeah you can set that so here's our pipe
uh so what we want to do is make the
pipe move
right and in order to implement behavior
you write a component normally you write
this in c sharp
or unity is implementation of they call
it javascript which is the complete
misnomer
a lot of people ask us why we didn't
just compile clojurescript to unity's
javascript and that's
unity's javascript is a very thin poorly
engineered shim on top of voo
which is itself a very thin you know
i'm not gonna but it's yeah nobody
really knows why
they did that but it's on unity
javascript is not real javascript so we
compile directly to the clr by code you
just don't feel
that noise so um to add
a component we need to write one first
and we don't have
the uh our ad component menu item is a
little bit buggy
normally just go to arcadia new
component
you can't really read that text but
that's what that menu item is uh
so i'm just gonna do it from the
tournament
let's create a folder on the class path
called flappy
and i'm going to make a
pipe.clj
so this is my five.clj so
this is what you would expect so we have
a couple of
uh nice things to use
so arcadia core has a lot of the core
interop
and component functionality
always included we always use it because
it's it's sort of understood that you're
working this environment you just these
are the basic things that you need
um let me save that
give it a second and our compiler
see that with the beach ball so part of
our part of what arcadia does is it's
able to pick up clj files
compile them correctly put them into our
folder make sure that unity can see them
so you'll see that if i go click on this
pipe
and say add component
uh i haven't created a component yet but
we'll be able to so
i can show you guys from the ruffle
so the rebel this is our apple into
unity that is working
um i can
i'm using sublime text uh forgive me for
that but
one of my one of my few devices um
so now i'm in the floppy pipe name space
and we've used arcadia core so i can
show you some of the stuff in arcadia
core you can
query the scene graph for objects with a
particular name
maybe
everything's breaking as it often does
so this is the building collapsing
now this is a use this should just do it
is it object named rather than optic
name yes
so the thing about uh function names
is all the letters have to be there
sorry about that
it's a quirk of unity so
object named will do a name look up into
the scene
and pick up
you know whatever object you need this
is a great way to be able to query and
and reach in
uh and what comes out is a unity like an
actual game object so this is a
reference c sharp type that you can do
all kinds of stuff too so you could ask
what is its
transform uh it's reflect we have
reflection warnings turned on uh because
we're optimizing but you could ignore
them
for the reference stuff so um so again
in unity everything is a game object and
game object is an empty just container
of components
so to do anything useful you have to
talk to a component
so here i'm requesting or querying
the transform component of the camera
object
so transform is what encodes position
rotation and scale and unity
so if i continue with this form
transform
position i get its position it's at 0 0
minus 10
and z minus 10.
so so i'm new to closure and i've been
doing c sharp
and like uh you know during your
languages for
a very long time and that syntax to me
is so beautiful and so exciting you just
shoot right in and this is an internal
form right like this isn't even
cool so i just love just being able to
do that it's very
very very elegant um other ways that the
the like i said the editor is great and
the rebel is great and they play
very very nicely together so
if you import selection um
so that'll return whatever object you've
selected with the mouse
so you can very easily like select
something with the mouse and then apply
ripple logic to it and then move back
and forth um
if you select a bunch of things
you get a sequence of all the objects is
this read only or can you manipulate
these objects yeah you can make it with
them you can uh you can do secret word
do whatever you want
well let me create something that so if
you have like some stuff that
you just want to play with
so i'm just going to select these guys
you could do lj
selection objects and you can
add these guys
so you come back and all of a sudden
they all have rigid body 2d
so rigidbody2d is the unity component
that gives an object mass in the physics
center
right yeah so they're totally you know
open to manipulation
for better or for worse sort of the
tension between
unity really wanting to do in-place
mutation and closure really wanting to
be closure
is it just an interesting tension that
we've been we've been balancing um
and then i can
go away so uh to make
the pipe move you uh you have to create
a
component that's the only way you
interact that's that's your sort of
interface to the unity system when
you're building again
so to create the pipe component
um so death component is a uh
is an arcadia i think it's particular to
arcadia
this is part of where we had to hack the
compiler to make it work with unity
so unity components have to inherit from
monobehaviour which is a unity
that's the unity component type and
so they need a particular superclass and
it has to emit a named type
so these are these two things there's no
closure construct that did both of these
things
um so we ended up sort of writing on a
special form which
it does exactly that it's a name type of
a particular supervisor
but other than that it basically behaves
like that type this is not true
so i can give it the parameters that i
or its fields
so it's going to move at a particular
speed
uh and then you have to implement
um one of unity's messages and
i say that with gigantic air quotes
because that that word is meaningless as
a formal meaning it's just
the um unity has a list
unity has a list that they call messages
oh let me see it says
y'all kind of read that yeah awake
late update so these are
these are functions these are methods
that if you implement them on your
component
unity will find it and call them at the
appropriate time so
on collision enter if your component is
attached
to an object that has a collider to give
it shape and a rigid body to give it
mass
and it bumps into something you're the
on collision
enter method will be called so these are
your hooks
into the into unity's event system um
of course it's c sharp object oriented
so you're expected to like you know
uh create a subclass and like implement
these methods uh and and
def component mirrors that in a def
typing kind of way
so the most important ones are update
this gets called once a frame and start
this gets called at the beginning these
are the ones
sort of most of the time
so to update
the way you make a pipe move is
oh you would not type into a type of
thing so update
this our
dev component will automatically insert
a protocol that you would like normally
write um
it just gets kind of obnoxious to have
to write a separate protocol for every
single
one of unity's 40 messages so we'll just
do that for you
again def component is intended to be
entirely just an involved form you sort
of do it and get away from it as quickly
as possible
so update we say this
so this refers to the uh the component
so this transform will get you access to
the transform
that uh so you can have components
talking to other components
so you'll get the transform that is
attached to the current object
then you feed it how much you want to
move in x y and z so
x we want to move uh
by whatever our speed is
and then y is zero and z zero
save that back in
compiles the component
and now i can say add component moving
pipe
and you can't see it but there's a
little speed
thing that shows up in the inspector
and even unity gives it a little icon
in the in the corner which i think is
hilarious like components get their own
icons you can see sharpest on the c
sharp icon
but in this case it's just a little
unity file icon because it has no idea
what it is but it's consuming it anyway
um so so we we've said sometimes that
arcadia works better than it should and
this kind of
completes the disintegration into the
actual visual gui it was like
more than we were expecting unity to be
capable of
did it need the type registration there
if you didn't have the type uh
annotation for float yeah um you
don't need it it'll emit a field of type
object
which means that unity is oh
so unity's default inspector won't
render a thing of type object
so you could i know it's really small
for you guys but it just disappears
um so that's not a huge deal um
you can write custom inspectors in unity
it's just nice the default one will work
with five fan pages and stuff
is that that's uh
yeah okay so basically just taking
anything that's named
like one of the beauty script methods
you know
um so if we jump back in here
and we run it so
we'll see nothing the speed is zero if
we set speed to one
she's off set to minus one it
comes back
video games
so what you the normal workflow
um is you would uh
sort of tweak your component and then go
back into unity unity does have a
code loading solution for for c sharp
it'll like compile and swap in
your components on the fly um but we
have a
replica there's like no need to worry
about that
and a workflow that we've settled in is
especially for rebel stuff
is to just forward declare a
function
because the component has to um
recompile
uh if you're going to update its
contents
you can't really update it from the repo
because it really has to hit unity's
compiler pipeline
but um when doing it from
uh if it's just sort of calling out to a
closure
bar then you could redefine that from
the rifle a lot uh
joseph parker who's the
very early doctors of arcadia sort of
really made this pattern kind of
a thing that we can't stop using so
all right this and i can paste that
right back in
and this will this will work
uh anyway that allows me to
here you don't need to pass speed uh oh
there we go
so this is a type uh moving pipe
and i'll be able to pick it up
so not compiled and now
we run it
and so it's still zero so i'm just gonna
make speed
0.1 and that moves
so i'm going to leave it running and i'm
going to do some stuff from the
rapple so i'm in the floppy pipe
name space um so
one of the interesting things about
ripple driven development of a
video game is um i ran into this while
building the demo
for um codemesh which is uh
i built a build a game with a bunch of
like cats wandering on a platform and
then falling off the platform
um i would like you know write some code
and try and
turn around all my classes follow the
platform and i couldn't really like i
had this code but all my accounts were
gone
um so in this case the pipe is gone and
if i tweak this
code you know i won't see one of the
things that
we uh i've started to do is
uh and this is the kind of stuff that
maybe folded into core eventually
i just created
just to reset the world function
so import the application namespace
so application load level
uh application
loaded so this is a unity trick
so you basically load you load a level
you load the current level
which flushes the state and like returns
it to what it was when it started
um so for java
so i revealed the ns form so now i
should be able to see
reset world and then reset world
brings our fight back this is a nice
trick to like you know if your world
sort of runs too much
and while you're making changes you can
bring it all back
um so the one thing uh
oh and it reset the speed to zero as
well
so
this guy's called uh oh
so it might be still called game object
i just never changed
so i'm just going to update this name
so now that now it's called pipe and now
i can
set its speed back to something
reasonable thanks that
object
so these are interrupt forms and uh
it's all visible
to c sharp so it goes into the flappy
pipe
namespace
so you get the component and we set the
speed
to be one
that doesn't like it
oh oh god yeah so
unity uh very good so this is a double
float
issue this might actually work
there we go yeah so unity um
and the reason i wrote float instead of
double up here is the habit that you get
into immunity unity wants everything to
be floats
closure once i think could be doubles
this is just like a bigger
noise so now we have reset world
and give it speed
oh right
so resetting the world change its name
too
so let's leave it at that so now we can
reset the world
and assign the speed uh so the problem
with the current implementation of speed
is that it it's too fast
even like a speed of one is too fast so
you can reduce the number to make it
slower
but the correct thing to do in game
development um
is you actually want to multiply the
speed by what's called delta time
um so that's the the number of seconds
since the last frame which is usually a
very very small number and that gives
you a smooth
you know time based uh
so now you're not moving one unit per
frame you're actually moving one unit
per second
so if i leave out this update
and i give it to speed now it's moving
at one frame per second right
minus one and now it should be moving
backwards there we go
so there's a pipeline
um and then you would go on right you
would say okay well
if the pipe goes too far so let's see
how far is too far because we want to
set it back to the beginning
so when it reaches about -1
let's just say that for now when it
reaches minus one you want to reset it
like you basically want the pipe to move
off screen and then come back to the
other side of the screen that's how you
create an
infinite series of pipes
so if uh less than
transform this transform
position x
minus one
set this transform position
two two
go
yeah it should be make sure that it's
actually calling it
what are the challenges oh yeah that's
calling your code so you can't really
see it but in the console it's just
printing
out new code uh all the time um
so yeah that's one of the challenges of
like building this this is still very
very alpha
you sort of don't know if the framework
is breaking or if you're breaking
um but in this case it is actually
picking up the code change so
uh if the position are you sure you want
a less than
it's moving to the left
so it might i imagine
so it moved to here this is where
oh yeah right now it's minus
this minus one so
if the position is less than one
that shouldn't make a difference but
is it the position to be
and so now it's printing out the values
minus 14.
so now let's actually print out i mean
do you think that you're less than
minus one so i'm getting a bunch of
truths
so this is definitely true
so this branch must be evaluating
oh does it just get updated again with
the speed which is still times the time
back to where it was how are we
so we're doing a translate which is
relative like it just moves it to the
left a little bit so that should be okay
i think the problem
is that i'm trying to set an individual
component
and unity generally doesn't like that so
let's try to set the whole position
to of just a new vector so vector 3 is
how unity encodes position let's just
see
vector three zero right now so delta
time is still from the beginning of
the time delta time is the number of
seconds since the last print
so it's like point zero zero zero one
and that's what
so you multiply one by by delta time and
you're you're now moving
per second and not per frame like one
unit per second
uh so let's try this actually i think
that was it
so now we know what vector three is and
we come back and we re-evaluate there we
go
there we go so the problem was uh
and this is just the way unity is built
uh it generally doesn't like you to
update
individual components of a position
which is the thing that i obviously tend
to forget um
they want you to reassign the whole
position when anyone goes because
positions are value types and they have
certain semantics but the important
thing for this talk is
that was entirely debugged right and
reasoned about live and interactively
whereas in c sharp or in you know any
other
comparable environment i'd be like
patching and recompiling patching
recompiling attachments
and for a you know bug that's not as
trivial as this
that stops being fun very very very fast
so we want to put this at
two and then zero zero
and now we have something that's a
little bit better maybe maybe two single
should be one
what does that look like there we go is
it
yeah that's good there we have a little
pipe and that
zero is a little high six through that
one no
wrong direction
there you go i have a pipe you have an
internet sort of
scroll of pipes
um and then the next thing i would do is
i would save this come back into unity
now that i've done my live rebel stuff
and i have a component that i'm happy
with
i can do the unity thing of
uh so i could i could do this in the
ripple as well but i'm going to do it
from the
inspector just to show just to show that
part of the experience
and so now i have this pipe
it's doing what i want and i can
duplicate it
and i can put this guy a little bit
differently
height
duplicate it
this guy's a different height
i think the wires are probably going to
get reset according to this logic
oh and they all have a speed of zero
so give them all a speed of one
let's see what that looks like
minus one i don't actually know geometry
i just sort of like
multiply things until it looks okay
oh so now the y's are the wires are
being reset uh right right
so let's let's actually fix that here
so this big reset because we're always
saying the y minus one uh what we
actually want to do is we want to set
the y to be this
transform position y so we don't ever
want to change their height let's say i
mean you can randomize it here you can
do whatever you want
but let's select the namespace and
reevaluate that
so now i can
one point two there we go so i got that
guy stays low
and uh this guy looks like a little
higher so three point nine
oh so now you're all right over there
the x values or yeah um
they like oh
oh yeah yeah because it's being reset
between one and minus one
so i just paused the game because i
wanted to like sort these things out a
little bit so that's zero
two at one put you at two
and i just wanna sort of tweak the
heights
that's for that guy that might be a
little too high
okay yep there
and let's pause it one more time
and
so i duplicated all of them and now we
rotate it
uh okay
so i do make games for a living that's
where it goes this is just what the
process is
then you
now if you just look in the screen at
the bottom which is what your users will
see
this starts to look like the terrain of
flappy bird and if we
wanted to get cute which is the whole
point of games
we multiply the original
we add to the original position
a random number so let's say a random
number between
by 0.1 make sure the right namespace
and yep there you go
so now the pipes are all right heights
um and you have this
very simple like little little terrain
going
um how are we doing on time
eight hey wanna do you wanna show
yourself off uh
sure i mean is it gonna take a while to
get a burden there um
well i mean i i can use the old bird
component
yeah so
so yeah i had the pipe where the the
pipes are the more sort of
and this is this is what the bird looks
like it's a
sort of daunting nine-lines of coat um
basically
in flappy bird uh the bird is always
just hopping upwards
so we say if any key is pressed then we
get access to the rigid body and we just
add
uh force to it and force is a parameter
that you can set externally
so to create the bird uh again as with
everything i create an empty game object
i attach the bird component
and i'm going to give it upward force of
positive one in y and zero in x so it
just goes straight up
to make it look like a bird i'm going to
add a sprite renderer
uh and then to make him flap
because we do not cut corners we add an
animator
and this is an animation that i set up
beforehand
so um oh and he needs a rigid body
because he's
so rigid body i'm going to
lower gravity so gravity is only at one
i'm going to set it to
0.2 just to slow things down a little
bit
and if we run
okay
so if you hold down the key it takes off
yeah every time
every time i tap it gives it a little
bit of force upwards what if you hold
down the key
yep false i believe in you
uh and then and then to round it off um
uh to make him actually collide i would
give him a circle collider
so colliders are what give things shape
in the physics engine you could i
definitely see the light green outline
of the bird that's what sort of
determines
determines how he will collide with
other objects uh and then i will give
the pipes which i'm going to use i'm
going to give the pipes box colliders
so he's shaped like a circle and the
pipes are shaped like boxes
and uh that should be it and then we
could sort of set up
our level
so that was a nervous stick command s
uh and when we uh duplicate these guys
here rotate them
so the reason um the pipes were popping
in and out of existence
is when you change things while the game
is playing unity doesn't retain it
um it's a which is by design
uh it allows you to change things
without sort of uh you know
permanently breaking your game uh so
then i think these guys need to go in
the opposite direction now
so let's do one i'll probably [ __ ] that
up
let's go
oh it actually works
oh now he's all the way up there
yeah so if he hits
you see that the pipe's actually dragged
um
so this is where if you wanted to make
it so that the game ended when that
happened you would use it on trigger or
on collision enter
and you would just make the word um
destroy the birds but for now you just
have this little sort of impossible
struggle against those
pipes
and that's um that's flappy bird in
arcadia
do we have time to show off uh a little
more magic
maybe just show you guys like 10 minutes
of something from a slightly different
perspective
um so um ramsay and i are working
together ramsay knows
uh unity better than i do i know closure
a bit better than ramsey does he's been
doing these
both of these perspective things for
like um about five years each and
uh um so i'd like to show
this is a very stateful um interrupt
heavy kind of approach to the unity
scene graph and
i'm going to quickly again um and
everything doesn't explode
and we'll copy that to live coding uh
show you guys um
some another stuff that you might
so um not because the infrastructure
here's bad but because of my
computer um so
okay uh my instinct as a quality
developer is to do
is to get as far away from anything
that's stateful and mutating and
difficult to reason about
um for as long as i can now that's
difficult to take as an absolute in
a game's context because the performance
considerations in games are completely
uncompromising and
if it's like 1.5 times slower you did uh
you have to do this at 60 frames a
second we have to run a
three-dimensional
physics simulation sometimes over like
tens of thousands of objects
each one calculating collisions and so
on and it's a messy
like the lowest level stuff you just
can't afford to be purely functional um
until maybe some future game sanctions
could do this but
they can um the uh uh
which you know isn't surprising us and
very demanding um however
there's usually some sort of higher
level uh
abstractions or like like part of game
design in general that you can rely on
so we have a experimental like
everything else
name space called hydrate which converts
between closure persistent maps
and unity components this is under the
conceit that
uh the unity scene graph can more or
less be represented as
uh associative data structures sort of a
database of associative data structures
um it's more or less flat sometimes it's
nested
uh most of the time it's flat so i'm
going to
uh start by showing you a bit
of the quads like just my workflow for
setting up some stuff this is
uh i was using to play with fraternities
and figure out how they worked and you
know
another thing that's worth mentioning
for those of you more used to the jvm
which
i'm supposed to do the clr has a very
interesting
feature called value types meaning that
you can extend
the range of primitive-ish types uh
vector 3 in
unity is a value type it's not a it's
not a reference type um
it's immutable uh all of the
and there's i think 281 value types just
in hindi you can
extend these you can define your own and
that's great it means that it makes
our work as closure programmers much
much easier we don't have to worry about
mutating things in the leaves of all
these components so
yeah it's important to mention that the
uh the functions that unity provides to
manipulate
vector threes quaternions for rotations
and matrices
all will run in in uh non-main threads
which is not usual for unity so you can
do like linear algebra in separate
threads and then you know pull it back
into the main thread
right we're very excited which brings up
another thing which is that um muting
the scene graph all runs in one
in the main thread immunity which is
nice in a way because
it means that we have certain we don't
have to think about concurrency too much
there
um it's bad because we don't have to
think about concurrency but um
so you know uh but
um but yeah for all the like spatial
computations you can do in another
thread or an agent or whatever you want
uh
you do have access to other crisis for
um it's just
not when you're changing the scene right
correct uh
so um here i have a disc uh in the world
and here is a form that i defined with
fscn
uh has a little garbage like fake corny
garbage collecting thing um i can show
you that macro right now
uh so what this does is if there's a
um it defines the bar uh if the var is
already in the scene and affects your
game object then it um destroys that
thing and then uh repopulates it you
know re-instantiates it with the
you know whatever it is you want this
means that from the riffle um
i can go to let's see uh
i can i can so change this somehow i can
move this over here
and then okay everybody see the
code yes is this big enough not that
fitness is this big enough to make it a
little bit bigger
a little bigger
so and then if you re-evaluate that form
just puts it back where it was before um
okay so i was trying to figure out how
tournaments work and how to pivot
objects i'm going to show you
a form here so first of all i started
out with
a little asymmetrical pointer
thing made out of unity primitives um
and you'll see that to create this i fed
in a
closure map with a certain nested
structure that's
i'd have to explain with more time than
we probably have right now
the point is i'm just manipulating uh
functional data structures to get this
pointer in the first place and then i
call hydrate on it as soon as hydrate
hits it it
does as and is doing this as fast as i
know how to make it right now
it's walking that uh that data structure
and
constructing a fresh unity object on the
basis of it each of the
keys there well most of the keys there
correspond to um
unity components underneath the top
level uh game object so the transform is
the transform object under transform you
have local scale which is the canonical
representation of where that
object is now um and here we go
okay so uh now we have pointer uh
trans i'm not very good at names uh
let's see
so uh this is a
it takes the existing thing in the um
scene you'll notice that i didn't
actually define
the map i'm using to construct the
pointer anywhere on the top level
i don't need to because it's already in
the scene so i
go here to dehydrate which is uh the
inverse
hopefully of hydrate it uh hopes to be
impotent with hydrate so you can just
populate something into the scene graph
and then dehydrate it
and after you do that twice i you you
wind up where you started
um so ideally the uh
okay so i used that to grab whatever
definition of that happened to be
then i have some other functions to find
there's spec plus spec scale
times these are just little conveniences
i wrote to reach into
a closure spec and
multiply or add the vector threes i find
out there
so when i do then where's the action
here it's uh okay so then um
under point under this thing i uh
i am going to make a series of a
sequence of um of the dehydrated speck
of that thing
in each one i'm going to uh
update i'm going to dig into the
transform local position
fields and there i'm going to call my uh
my point pivot
function which is defined
here uh and this is a little sort of
quasi-polymorphic uh thing that takes
a it gets out of vector three it takes
two vector3s it takes something that
could be either a
vector3 or a quaternion if it's a um
if it's a vector three it assumes that
it's euler angles euler sorry
euler angles uh and um translates that
into a quaternion
then it does a little bit of math down
here which again we're
not gonna go through now but it's it's
sort of straightforward you know you
translate to the point then you
rotate one thing then you rotate back
and forth back and turn
uh so
um down here pointer trans i
can uh zoom out a little
okay i'll evaluate that and i get a ring
of
these pointers that are sort of um
turning around the
central point right um and i'm
processing all these again as
no functional data structures in order
to arrive at these this non-functional
data structure representation
um sort of riffing on that i can do much
the same thing again both sides of
different parameters
and i get a lot more so
and this is on the right line we need to
re-evaluate anything or
stop the world and you can do this in a
running game
and then if i want to tweak some uh
something here let's see i think
it's that scale this work okay so 22 so
let's make that 50
and it makes them larger uh
i can bring that down to 10 it makes a
tight little sphere
um and so you can you know you can keep
treating things like that as much as you
want
what does that do if they kill someone
well this you need
three areas
it's pretty cool so uh okay and then um
now as i'm evaluating things in the
buffer it just
uh streams it directly to the uh
unity um this is running all the time
we're not using anything we wrote our
own uh
little record thing it's a uvp socket so
it's running constantly you never have
to set it up
or tear it down there's some caveats
with that if you're not going to go into
that
um because so uh and ripple is being
imported
yeah everyone's being ported right now
by david miller it's a um
god among man who uh who's responsible
for maintaining the closure clogged
break
uh so we're waiting for that and that'll
be really cool and come with all kinds
of other
fun things that'll make integration
easier in the meantime i'm using
inferiorities
in august anyway so the uh the
uh process of sending things over the
wire is pretty fast um
so you can just lean on the emacs on
like the formula
uh so in here i'm just pivoting this
around some
um point right okay so i'll show you
guys one more thing
uh first i'm going to tear down the
scene which i don't have a
cute little thing for right now so i'm
going to do it manually
um and this is what i'm about to do is
probably going to be apart too small for
you to actually see but
they're with me uh so just selecting the
district
and going into the unity console and
getting rid of some stuff
now i hope this works i'm going to go
with another namespace i have
uh
okay
all right are we good okay and
let's see let's try to print out a
keyword sort of
no yeah so okay
so i've got some stuff i'm gonna make
this big um
got some stuff to find here i just made
some platforms and then
a tilted platform using the same
technique you can see the
uh the maps i'm using here um
just close your data again you don't
have to worry about the types of the uh
of the loops here these all correspond
to unity types but
um whatever i'm you can just represent
them as
uh vectors so you don't have to think
about that or import um
all of the heterogeneous little things
that might be interesting
um and
then after that i think we're running
now so i can just
make some make a grid of the cubes
there um you can see they're drifting
off a little here maybe if you squint um
that's because the off this is all live
it's all running
um they have physics attached to them
and then to make it more exciting i'm
going to position the camera
with it
down here
and then
so this is all stateful right obviously
we're not doing any of this enclosure i
don't know how to it would probably be
uh the
uh but to set up the scene we did all
that enclosure and
we can go back here and reevaluate
callers
and the back um so it swept up all the
existing game objects that i defined
before
and re-instantiated new ones up there
more elaborate versions of that macro
might just
keep them around which would be more
performant and just change their fields
such that they're back where they
started
and this is a pattern in game
development in general where you
maintain an object pool and
sort of enable or disable them it means
that you don't have to pay for
allocation which is by far
the most expensive part of any of this
stuff you can do that to everybody so
those things are back
poppers the back you just keep going um
you can uh if these guys get more of
them
and that is 20 is 20 wide rather than 10
wide
uh you can change the um
make them use gravity themselves
so they're not it's a little bit slow
because like this instantiated a bunch
of things
so other space is also using gravity set
the type false
uh increase their mass let's make the
mass 100
now that's going to the mean when we and
then
let's make the mass of the plotters uh
one and then when we drop the powers on
them
they just sort of roll off because of
the differences in their mass
um yeah so uh that's and this is an
extensive system you can extend it to
types that you've
had in itself it's um all macro there's
a macro that generates it
well i go to the income but um uh
the point is all this aots so all this
is being constantly aot'ed
um on to uh some canonical
representation
um that will live yellow and uh
that means that for hydrate to work out
how to do all this like
type specific stuff um i don't know the
interface
into this macros it doesn't really
matter right now anyway so that's the uh
that's hydrate this is sort of hopefully
at some ways to
integrate persistent objects with the
imperative c graph um
it's closure on android and the boat
time is very slow initially
how do you have the same problem so um
like the
uh we this we've been working on this
um increasingly sort of full-time for
six months
uh and now it's kind of working uh
um but we haven't even tried exporting
it to mobile yet uh for one thing
we expect that the uh
so you know you can't um do reflective
code emission
in ios for example uh and that means you
can't use eval
so we have to figure out some way to
which we will because we
we're going to have ios x4 but um we
need to figure out how to disable eval
for example
and under that um umbrella we haven't
even tried it on android
but yeah as a like a unity dev um
i i have no reason to expect the load
time to be any different from
had you anything in c sharp the byte
code for
many cases uh is indistinguishable from
what c-sharp generates so
the problem is is the loading the
closure libraries in runtime it's just
it takes 10 seconds just to start up
you know the mobile was just unusable
heyot closure levers yeah
yeah wow yeah so i mean
unity does uh so yeah this is this is
the kind of
place i mean people asked us why we
didn't just ride a game engine right
here right yeah on the weekend uh so
unity yeah they've been building this
thing for over a decade and that's the
kind of stuff that they take very very
seriously so
i'm sure they do uh by code level
optimizations for
like you know mobile targets so i would
expect it to be better again we haven't
seen it but i i think that that'll but
that that class of problem will be
better
in arcade we also um
are this is our branch of the closure
clr
uh compiler and if we when we encounter
things
like enclosure or in the compiler that
um
are show stoppers for us we can't um so
if there's something
um if we can see some path to making
it easier for a platform to do this then
um we're not afraid to
screw stuff up right because it's
understood that you know you're running
arcadia code is running inside of unity
and that's an assumption that we're you
know
comfortable to me uh so we we're not
cowboy about it we try and like
maintain parodies not just or like you
know uh just stick to
closer clrs there as much as possible um
but there are situations where i mean we
already have def component and inside of
that is something called def class which
is a semantic deviation
from closure so basically whatever needs
to happen to make this thing perform and
like work well we're sort of willing to
do
because we have our own compiler have a
question where is c
where is clear clr in relation to jb
it's right up to date um so it's at 1.7
it's got transducers
uh it does not yet have a core because
it's
more uh qualitative purposes is one guy
doing most of this stuff
uh so it um it's not an n-rebel it does
not of course async
oh no it does have core async but we
can't use poor async because it uses a
later version of
um of mana and that was actually one of
the
motivations maybe ramsey mentioned this
for our fork was that
unity uses a um of several versions ago
versionable
monopoly but several major versions yeah
so
um so uh
but we're in communication with david
miller um and
we want to get core async in here as
soon as we can um
we might be able to make the canonical
implementation of core async compatible
with this version of mono that's
that's the code but it's pretty it's
pretty much completely updated yeah i
just
didn't i just don't know much
uh unity is of course okay about that
um part of it may land in unity five
which is what they're you know they're
sort of working on right now
um no dates have been announced this is
the short answer but soon
uh it's not gonna bump it up all the way
right let's get on it up to three
probably about 4.5 which is what the
rest of the civilizations have
yeah that's a little better this is one
of the main differences between
uh your version of closure and the
one david miller maintained um the main
visible one is well we're trying to we
keep getting these um
little little bugs and little things and
our demo policy is to patch them and
then push them upstream into the main
closure clr
the last thing we want to do is to fork
the potency community or anything insane
like that
um the one thing we allowed ourselves to
do
again is introduce this new um sort of
dirty special form
uh deb class which enables you to use
inheritance and type definitions but
then we paper it under a bunch of macros
and stuff um
such that the only thing that really
faces the user
is uh to uh without
digging is to generate a class that um
yeah that extends uh mod behavior so the
best
difference here and so we've already had
um
a couple of our optimizations have been
like folded to the main line right now
so we
i think the big thing we did was we
optimized type lookup by
orders of magnitude in some cases um
because again the performance
pressures that you know we're under are
sort of categorically different from
anything else so yeah our policy is as
much as possible
uh patch and push-up strength
oh yeah so this is a death form so the
actual object in unity is bound to that
variable
so this says uh def def sem nexin
um followers so this binds
the um variable clobberers the var
plotters to uh the result of this
hydration in other words this is tied
to this thing here so then what happens
when i redefine it
is i delete that thing um it's
a managed runtime so there's no like
destructors or really or anything but
uh it knows the object and then um it
redefines collaborators as a result of
doing this again the other thing gets
garbage collected
and uh and you start over so
uh the question you need is a reason why
they're having trouble updating to
lasers because they
heavily modified manual their
modifications as i understand them
weren't heavy uh they are there they
have their own fork
my understanding is that it's a
licensing issue with xamarin and the
mono team
um uh so what a licensing issue
uh that's which is really frustrating
actually that's not like a technical
showstopper uh but yeah that's
that's my understanding it also works
well enough for them i guess
um part of the process of unity
supporting a new platform is them
pointing mono to that platform
so i think updating mono would mean
they'd have to
really like redo their ports across all
their platforms
and unity supports a lot more than
what's listed in the window
you could like make games for roku
technically like if you really wanted to
i didn't
find the field but that's the thing but
um so a big part of their
uh you know effort is like just
massively reporting mono
um so yeah i think it's mostly licensing
on some technical
things
well what are you guys doing this is for
fun or yeah but
what are we doing because um
because i like games i've been i was
doing uh creative coding stuff
for a while uh and then
i got a closure um there weren't really
any
like industrial strength um
creative coding tools and non-imperative
frameworks i mean
i'm sure there's comments to that but
for all intents and purposes
i mean you can wrap processing in like
closure but that's not going to do this
so
um yeah so we just wanted to be making
games
and doing other game like things like
visualizations
um installations anything
using uh using closure rather than an
imperative
yeah and i mean i've been writing names
for um five years
uh in c sharp mostly and it's just i
mean c sharp is good
like it's could be it could have been a
lot worse right but the
imperative stuff it just gets it's just
taxing after a while and
i've hit enough i knew in theory you
know this stuff is hard to reason about
and all that but i've just
personally hit enough like anecdotal
real life
i have no idea how you arrived at this
state and i have no way of knowing how
to arrive in that state
and the client is coming in six hours
right so like i've just been there so
many times
that um i'm excited to try something new
right so
and and this everything that i've seen
in closure like again i'm very new to
the language everything that i've seen
has been
so good it's so consistent uh and well
well-reasoned it's just a joy to write
in so that's why i'm doing it
awesome